on a multiple choice exam each question  has four options with one correct answer  with probability two over three a  student knows the correct answer and  marks it otherwise the student guesses  randomly with equal chance to each  option if a correct answer was marked  what is the probability the student was  guessing  to solve this problem we will make a  tree with all of the different  possibilities there is a two-thirds  chance the student knows the question  and marks it correctly otherwise there  is a one-third chance the student is  guessing and that'll be a one over four  chance the student guesses correctly  we know the correct answer was marked so  we add up the probabilities of these two  options this will be 2 over 3 plus 1  over 12. that will make for a total of 9  over 12. we then want the conditional  probability the student was guessing so  this will be 1 over 12 divided by 9 over  12 which is equal to one over nine and  that's the answer